hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2016 american comedy and drama movie
called dirty grandpa the movie begins
with jason kelly who is attending a
funeral for his grandmother she passed
away after fighting cancer for 10 years
his obnoxious cousin nick suddenly
appears and talks nonsense about their
grandmother telling jason that dying
because of cancer is a conspiracy turns
out that nick is high so jason attempts
to stop him from messing around by
hugging him
in the church jason's grandfather dick
gives his final goodbye to his wife
jason is also present there and is
accompanied by his fiancee meredith
the couple planned to get married in the
following week
after the funeral dick asks jason to
drive him to florida as a personal favor
since his driving license was taken away
and nick is not reliable at all
jason and his dad initially refused the
request but jason later reluctantly
agrees to help out his grieving grandpa
the next day before he leaves meredith
seems annoyed because jason has to leave
before their upcoming rehearsal brunch
she even forces him to drive her pink
mini car for a short trip to florida
jason then picks his grandpa up only to
find that the man is wanking in his
living room
he is horrified and runs away
surprisingly the grandpa seems energetic
despite just losing his wife
they hit the road and stop at a diner
for a moment where jason shares to dick
about his job as a lawyer at his
father's firm
the grandpa thinks that his job is
boring while his grandchild keeps trying
to convince him that working as a
corporate lawyer is cool
just as dick leaves to buy some liquor
at the store next door a young woman
named shadia spots jason and recognizes
him who turns out to be her ex-classmate
she tells her friend lenore about his
photography skill but she and the other
guy bradley don't really care about that
afterward shadia approaches jason
attempting to talk to him
however he doesn't remember her and
thinks that she's a waitress who wants
to collect the check
she takes his money and runs away with
her friends
shortly after the real waitress comes to
him to collect the money
he immediately chases after them and
catches her before they manage to drive
away
this time jason recognizes her but dick
suddenly appears and pretends to be a
college professor which attracts lenore
she attempts to tease the grandpa and
they both plan to meet up again in
daytona beach but jason and shadia are
against it
just after the teenagers leave jason
takes dick golfing where he spots two
women from a distance he immediately
drives the golf buggy towards them
trying to flirt with them dick admits
that he's a licensed golf professional
and offers his help to teach one of the
women
while dick is away jason secretly tells
the women that his grandpa is not in a
good state due to his wife's death
they immediately leave which upsets dick
he finally reveals that he wants to use
this long-awaited trip as a short escape
where he can make love as much as he can
jason is annoyed with dick's misbehavior
but still agrees to go along with a trip
jason tries to play some golf but gets
distracted by his grandpa until his
phone suddenly rings and dick sees the
message from lenore inviting them to
join the beach party on their way to
daytona meredith calls jason stating her
intention to put their wedding
announcement on the new york times
website but he keeps getting distracted
by the nearby environment
she even learns that the two are at
daytona beach which makes the fiancee
anxious
they finally arrive at the beach and run
into the teenagers
shadia talks to jason and seems
attracted to him while the grandpa
flirts with lenore
suddenly lenore's other friends cody and
bra appear and invite dick and jason to
the pool party which the grandpa can't
resist
there dick challenges a guy to a
drinking competition
unbeknownst to the others dick secretly
put drugs in one of the cups before that
jason also participates in the
competition but he accidentally drinks
from the cup that contains the drugs
in the evening the party continues where
jason suddenly goes wild and crazy to
make things worse he subsequently smokes
a crack from a local drug leader which
makes him crazier than ever instead of
helping his grandchild dick takes a
picture of jason naked while teasing a
stranger he then takes a motorbike and
rides away
the next morning jason awakens finding
himself in the middle of the beach naked
he suddenly gets a call from his fiancee
who is confused about the drawing on his
forehead
he immediately adds a video effect to
hide the swastika sign while a child
approaches him to touch the buzzy bee on
his crotch
from a distance the boy's father thinks
that jason is molesting his son thus he
pushes him off as the cops show up and
arrest him
dick tries to convince the amateur
officers that he's a lawyer
however they don't believe him due to
his appearance as he begs to the officer
for a phone call dick eventually comes
to the police station to release his
grandchild
before he leaves the woman officer gives
him a 1990s close from a murder victims
jason gets angry and states that he
can't do it anymore he drops his grandpa
off at a retirement house to meet his
old buddy stinky
however the man only has a month to live
and just wants to spend it playing bingo
since then jason finally understands
dick's desire to spend his remaining
time doing what he likes
meanwhile dick makes it clear that he
has to make love with lenore he also
adds that it's what his wife wanted
which is to move on and live his way the
way he wanted to
jason then drives dick to daytona beach
again where a dance music festival is
happening
dick and jason are challenged to get on
stage to participate in a flexing
competition it is a one-sided
competition until jason realizes that
everyone is recording his action
afraid that he will go viral and cost
him his job he runs off stage and the
other team wins by default afterward the
ex-special forces grandpa grabs a
confetti and fills it with a bottle he
then shoots cody who is celebrating the
victory in the face breaking his nose
that night jason and dick dress up
preparing themselves to go to a
nightclub where lenore and shadia are
they get drunk and jason gets closer to
shadia
they have fun on the dance floor until
dick confronts several thugs to defend
bradley and challenges them to fight
outside the club dick beats the crap out
of four of them before taking on the
leader tyrone
he humiliates him while making him
apologize to bradley for making fun of
him in the morning jason takes shadia
for a walk while pretending to be a
photographer
at some point the pair almost kiss but a
phone call ruins their sweet moment
long story short they reconcile with the
thugs at the nightclub while dick is
getting closer and closer with lenore
while jason and shadia are singing
together on the stage cody sneaks by
them and stuffs a large bag of wheat in
jason's coat at the same time he
accidentally finds dick's driver's
license realizing that he's not a
professor
after the party jason rethinks his
relationship with meredith planning to
call off his wedding
he also intends to tell the truth to
shadia and dick attempts to prevent him
from doing so
as he enters the room jason gets punched
in the face while cody reveals dick's
real identity to everyone who is
surprisingly a former special forces
operative a fact that no one in the
family knew about cody also tells them
about jason's engagement which breaks
shoddy's heart
jason tries to convince her about his
feelings towards her but she has already
pissed at him despite that lenore
blatantly states that she still wants to
make love with dick
unfortunately the cops show up and
arrest jason for the weed in his jacket
dix bails his grandchild out again for
the second time
this time he admits that the other
purpose of the trip is to prevent jason
from getting married to meredith because
he thinks that she's not right for jason
dick used to be a bad father and he
doesn't want everything happening to
jason's dad to happen to him
jason gets really angry and decides to
return to atlanta to proceed with a
wedding he attends the rehearsal brunch
with meredith where they sing the same
song that he sang with shadia earlier
during the presentation dick hires a man
to hack into the slides and puts their
pictures from the trip which include
jason naked along with a picture of
shadia
jason eventually admits that he can't
marry meredith to which she responds
that she slept with nick while he was
away
jason happily leaves the hall and meets
dick outside who tells him that shadia
is on a bus headed for a cruise
they attempt to drive away with the drug
dealer's ice cream truck while jason's
father shows up and threatens jason that
he'll lose his job if he leaves
the drug dealer tasers the father and
they go away
however they are being chased by the
cops as they exceed the speed limit
thanks to dick's driving skill they
eventually catch up with shadia's bus
but the bus driver won't pull over
dick speeds up and drives towards the
bus until the vans collide
jason immediately approaches the woman
and apologizes to shadia for lying
he tells her that he wants to join her
on the trip since he just broke up and
is jobless they finally kiss but the
moment is ruined by the cops
jason's father with his philly face
shows up and defends his son
dick returns home with jason's father
and apologizes to him for not being a
good father as dick arrives at his room
he is extremely happy when he finds
lenore has been waiting for him there
she still wants to have fun with him
even after knowing that he's not a
professor
at the end of the movie the old man's
desire is finally fulfilled
in the post-credit scene it's seeing
jason standing next to shadia with a
baby in his hands at a baptism turns out
that the baby is dick's son with lenore
and jason and shoddy are the boys
godparents
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching